the last two days it's been almost 3 000
cases per day and what you have to do is
put that against the backdrop
of the previous seven days
where on each of those days the kind of
case
counts we've seen through testing have
been in the range of
shall we say 1400 to 1700.
so this is a big change it's now
consistent over two days
and it is of great concern at this point
i think you know we've been able to
relax a bit over the summer the disease
levels have been
really quite low in the uk through the
summer
but these latest figures
really show us that um much as people
might like to say oh well it's gone away
this hasn't gone away this is a virus
we're going to have to live with
and if we're not careful if we don't
take this
incredibly seriously from this point in
um we're going to have a bumpy ride over
the next few months
what is the reason do you think for such
a considerable increase
well people have relaxed too much people
have relaxed too much
and um now is the time um
for us to re-engage and realize that
this
is a continuing threat to us um
it's all very well saying that hospital
admissions and deaths
are at a very low level in the uk which
is true
but if you look further into the
european union
you can see that where case numbers rise
initially in the younger parts of the
population
they do in turn filter through and start
to give
elevated rates of disease and hospital
admissions
in the older age groups and we know that
that then becomes
a serious public health problem so
that's my concern that if we don't get
on top of this
if people don't start to take this
seriously again
then um there is a risk that that's
where we will end up
and let's be clear that the epidemiology
is very clear that there is a rise in
all age groups
but it is really really much more marked
in the 17 to 21 years age group
than any other and for the first time
i think i see a trend that
this is no longer about disease in those
specific
hot spots such as leicester a few months
ago
the north west more recently but there
is a more general
and creeping geographic trend across the
uk
across england that disease levels
are now beginning to turn up on a wider
basis
wider geographical basis and that again
is really a signal that we've got to
change this now
got to start taking it seriously very
seriously again
do you think there may need to be a
tightening
of some of the restrictions that were
eased
this is very new news i think public
health policy officials
and politicians are going to need a
little time
to absorb this but they are going to
have to think about
how we manage this um and how we do so
not in a short-term way not about the
next six days
not about the next six weeks but about
the next six
months and how we get through this until
the spring
so would you say at least in your view
there shouldn't be any further easing
in the next six months i would say that
we've really got to take this very
seriously now
um it is clear that the level of
compliance
with the advice and the rules that have
been set
is very variable indeed and indeed i
heard another of your
interviewees comment on um
people organizing parties and gatherings
and so forth
um you know of course we all want to do
this kind of thing
but the downstream consequences are that
we get
increased transmission and i am you know
quite concerned that we must take this
seriously so that we don't end up
with a spreading problem over the next
few weeks and months
and just just finally the message to
younger people who might feel they're
being stigmatized or blamed here
is the risk of spreading it
inadvertently to older members of the
population is that right
if the data and it's all about the data
said
that the problem was in
people in in england aged 50 to 59
not heeding the advice and the disease
rates were climbing
extraordinarily in that particular age
group
i'd be very quick to point the finger at
the 50 to 59 year olds
i'm not pointing the finger at anybody
i'm telling you
telling you all and all your listeners
what the data show
and the data show that the particular
problem
is currently in the 17 to 21 year age
group
and is that because of gatherings
basically
in people's houses because of close
social contact um this disease thrives
unfortunately on the things we love
doing which is getting together
and being social beings which is what we
are
it is just very unfortunate that that is
so
but when we break those
social distancing rules particularly in
enclosed spaces
and particularly with conditions of
overcrowding
then we get rapidly into situations of
rapid
disease transmission and just finally
explain
again to the or general audience why if
it's 17 to 20 or one-year-olds who
probably won't get seriously ill
there is a particular problem for why
does society and why it leads to
hospitalizations
17 to 21 year olds
in company with really all other
adult age groups shed the virus
quite efficiently and so the fact that
17 to 21 year olds
are not becoming ill means they're lucky
because of their age but it also and
they forget that because the disease
is not severe for them that they are not
very potent spreaders
and after these parties they go home to
their more elderly parents
a couple of days later they
when they're infectious but not yet
having symptoms
they go and visit grandparents and
that's how the problem begins
we get this spread into the older
segments of families and once it gets
there as you know
as we all know from the previous
experiences of march april and may
that it then becomes a very serious
problem
that takes a long while to sort out
and i'll ask one final one if i may some
are saying well hang on
hospitals are much better at dealing
with sicker patients
in intensive care
it's being managed better there's a lot
more testing
it shouldn't be as bad as march are you
saying it could yet be
you're right that physicians have become
more experienced in managing
covid but at this point in time
although we have the very important news
that dexamethasone
a very common steroid reduces
mortality in seriously ill patients in
hospital
it's a very important step forwards but
it's not a miracle cure it's a long way
from a miracle cure
so for example what it really means is
if
um out of 10 patients on the intensive
care unit
four would die with dexamethasone
treatment
we might get that down to three or two
and a half
so from that perspective yes it's
important
no it's not a revolutionary cure
and we still have a long way to go in
fighting this disease
is there finally a danger the
authorities including yourselves as
chief and deputy chief medical officers
and the government
will lose control of this
i think we've got a much much better
intelligence network through the daily
deliberations of the joint biosecurity
center
than we ever had in uh months gone by
we obviously have remarkably large
quantities of testing that we can now do
and so
our kind of intelligence on this
organism
is better than it's ever been um we
are in a position now where we can spot
these signs
such as the signs we talked about at the
beginning of the interview
and uh let people know what we see
let people know that they have to now
start taking this
more skills and we can consider what the
next
correct moves are